gad gagner je voulais dire ce passe un
truc de fou avec toi c'est une star dans
le monde en tire le voit partout aux
états unis au maroc à boulogne paso
partout je vous laisse et des lieux où
on aurait peut-être aperçu la tête de
gad elmaleh est-ce qu'on a croisé gad
elmaleh dans le bus entre l'art et
clichy et bonne nouvelle oui oui penser
que oui oui c'est possible ça non
regardez par contre on a causé son
cousin gad elmaleh ou est-ce qu'on a
croisés gad elmaleh qui essayait de
passer incognito festival de cannes
ouais ouais c'est aussi oui oui deux
fois deux fois une fois on ne papillon
et une fois en touche ou regardent que
j'aime et non est-ce qu'on a croisé gad
en thaïlande avant qu'ils gagnent de
l'argent en rêvant d'une banque
non car ici mais ça c'est gad elmaleh la
croix d'anzin
est-ce qu'on a croisé gad elmaleh se
présenter aux élections municipales de
casablanca la connaissez son cousin
regardez adèle mallet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est exceptionnel ce qu'on a croisé gad
en quarts de finale de la ligue des
champions
ah oui oui oui oui ces gars d'el millan
regardez c'est ricardo montolivo et
ressemble et les beaux gosses ça va
chauffer quand tu te fais mais c'est pas
possible
mais c'est pas possible sans déconner
est-ce qu'on a croisé gars le fils de
gad et de bilal hassani pour le prochain
casting de the voice
regardez je vous le dis on l'a pas
encore croisé mon recherche activement
la personne regard des gardes suivait
partout dans bestway tu l'avais vu le
gars le promettent le gala d'obama lee
ouais tu l'as tuée dans le l'autre je
les ai vus mais grave ya eu plein plein
de vannes à celui-là c'est sûr mais
plein de vannes sur instagram et il y
avait une image séparés comme ça ex que
tu commandes ce que tu reçois y avait
mais je sais pas qui c'est en fait on
devrait on devrait l'inviter non